et maintenant j'accueille
le capitaine de l'équipe de france de
football marcel desailly
vous avoir depuis l'état de celle ci on
vous appelle de rock ses surnoms comme
ça qu'on m'a un milan c'était la digue
humaine puisque je joue a mis le terrain
way où le géant noir c'est moins sympa
et on va dire une montre trop aussi
aussi marché beaucoup plus sympa leur
tête le capitaine des bleus depuis
septembre 2000 vous avez remplacé celui
qui est sans doute votre meilleur ami
didier deschamps qui étaient ici à
quelques semaines qui en plus je crois
que vos femmes sont amies vous êtes
parent de ses enfants il est par
l'échangé c'est vrai ça va je veux de
potes c'est mon pote on a débuté
ensemble enfin quand même un voyage
d'être énorme centre de formation assure
alors vous dit en parlant de votre rôle
de capitaine c'est important pour les
relations presse mais en fait sur le
terrain donc l'équipe de france joue il
ya onze capitaine pas vu que quand même
toute l'équipe a quand même un gros
bagage vainquant expérience bruyante ou
de haut niveau quoi ouais ouais ils
pourraient lizarazu pour être capitaine
tout à fait oui zidane sûr est que
derrière moi je sais même pas qui en
fait le deuxième capitale et peut-être
10 ou zidane et vice capitaine
oui on va vous me l'apprenez voilà il
semblerait que j'ai souvent qui donnait
des ordres lorsque l'entraîneur quand
même mais bon en général aux tables
j'avais fait quelques fois sur le
terrain bon on est amené à changer
tactiquement parce que l'entraîneur est
un peu trop loin son capitaine
quelquefois peut prendre la
responsabilité de faire évoluer une
évolution actuelle
voilà alors la bombe sidérait de la
beauté de ce tome je trouve qu'ils ne
bougent pas j'ai envie de lui chez geos
est pas loin
ils font plus baraqué plaisir à
gérardmer
non plus dans l'habit va se faire la
bise j'ai plus l'habitude et vire et les
apps et embrassés mais je veux rattraper
non ça c'est qu'à la télé font ils font
part à mon avis sont assez minces à tous
non mais c'est vrai que là des biens il
ya eu un petit problème quand même
marcel la ba oui senna drop
non les [ __ ] non cotés pendant le match
voilà c'est ça je voulais dire vous
savez on a abordé ce match où bon comme
d'habitude mais disons que les espagnols
avaient une petite motivation
supplémentaire par rapport à nous à
l'euro il s'était fait un petit peu
bousculé bon ils avaient à coeur sur
leurs terres de faire remettre un petit
peu les choses au point qu'en avec des
joueurs qui jouent dans des grands clubs
real de madrid et ses différences de
motivation nous on était dans notre
motivation classique de match amical
mais euh bon vous avez quelque chose en
plus il jouait une compet quoi espagnol
le matin même les erreurs aussi on est
on a colonisé vous vous y avait juste
pour jouer au ballon sympas ils ont pris
ça au sérieux
regardez le match pour s'apercevoir que
bon ils ont ils ont quand même plus
d'agressivité que non c'est là où ils
sont un peu sûr de lui gary un peu non
voilà un peu un peu plus alors à parler
un peu de votre carrière à l'issue de la
coupe du monde et quitter milan pour
chelsea où il avait déjà franck leboeuf
vous regretter d'avoir quitté milan
c'est assez difficile quitter milan
quand même je vais rire culture
italienne me convenait parfaitement à
dire
le stade était magnifique l'organisation
du milan ac je veux dire elle est unique
mais bon c'est une nouvelle expérience à
terme été remis aux enfants d'apprendre
l'anglais quand même maintenant que
tapie était à l'om vous envisagé de
retourner à marseille
non je veux dire pour le moment ils sont
en train de mettre en place toute une
structure pour pouvoir déjà bien
terminer la saison et la recommencer la
saison prochaine mais bon ça c'est les
journalistes qui parlent à droite et à
gauche veut dire ça fait trois ans que
ighil qui sont intéressés par moi mais
bon ils n'arrivent pas à faire venir
aucun club français est capable de faire
venir un ses internationaux donc à par
anelka qui a mené dernièrement mais donc
moins une réalité aujourd'hui que bon
les gars il faut qu'il faut qu'ils se
décident où ils reprennent où ils
reprennent pas moyen d'en parler comme
ça chaque année
ouais l'heure initialement et puis après
cette volonté sur un garçon comme moi
qu'à 32 ans bon le club il s'est dit bon
je l'investis sur lui mais derrière
récupère pas les sous des bâches et de
carrière devant pour qu'ils récupèrent
leur mise
tout à fait vous voulez vous arrêté en
2002 vous 2002 dans ses alentours ont su
passionner donc que l'on sait pas ce que
ça peut durer encore n'est pas prêt de
voir deschamps laurent blanc vous
retourner à l'om c'est pas ça c'est
qu'il ya une réalité aujourd'hui que les
clubs français peuvent pas assumer
bon bah le jour où il y en aura un qui
franchira le pas bon on va peut-être que
on lave on a parlé aussi du psg et
chelsea a refusé une offre à 110
millions de francs pour vous racheter et
chelsea voudrait 150,2 millions de
francs pour vous la laissez partir donc
pour le psg qu'il garderait en 2004 dans
cet été il ya des clubs qui se sont
approchés mais mon club il a dit écoute
est bon de sailly aujourd'hui il faut un
minimum de 100 millions de francs pour
récupérer le même joueur avec le même
rendement qu'en mai il nous faut 100
millions pour récupérer un jeune et
c'est donc c'est tout le discours et a
été comme ça à preuve en fait votre seul
vrai objectif c'est le mondial-2002
j'imagine ont cédé ouais quand même je
veux dire ça sera un petit peu le petit
feu d'artifice avant d'arrêter la
carrière quand même on a fait pas mal de
choses j'espère qu'il y en a encore de
belles
dites les bleus c'est ce qui me redonne
le moral tous les jours quand on n'a pas
envie d'aller bosser cv bleue qui
redonne le moral on habite à l'étranger
quand même il ya des fois où on a un
petit peu quelques petits coups de
cafard et le fait de revenir en france
et retrouver ses collègues qui ça marche
bien et surtout on se retrouve en gros
pour l'impression d'être en colonie mais
non c'est vraiment sympa vraiment
magnifique
houston non il ya deux jours de ça
j'avais pas envie d'aller à
l'entraînement je vous la vérité il
devait faire 5° à londres il pleuvait le
terrain était boueux et je n'ai pas
envie non
c'est dur entre le monde y en a qui
disent que non à peine du pognon et
alors